Ryan's with us in Cincinnati hey Brian
how are you I'm great thank you Dave for
taking my call
sure what's up I have been offered a
buyout from a former company on a
pension okay and I have a point of view
on it but I was hoping that I might be
able to understand your your thought
process how big the money in the pension
are they have size or is this a small
operation the company is fortune 250
okay they currently have an activist
investor that's looking to do some
financial engineering mm-hmm but the
stocks gone up about 15 X in the last 20
years yeah and is your pension in the
stock no the okay that's the type of
company it is I got you okay good so I
have not received the formal offer but I
know that it will be coming in a third
quarter
right now and I've rounded down to make
this easy at 65 years of age I would
receive $2,000 a month and I'm 45 and
the buyout offer is going to be 480
thousand okay all right without putting
it in the calculator and trying to do
that on the radio let me tell you what I
will find 90 plus percent of the time
okay they use a discount methodology for
discounting the present discounting the
future value of that stream of payments
to a current value based on your age
today the you know in other words the 80
thousand a day would grow to X when
you're 65 and that X would create the
$24,000 a year you follow me yeah okay
and the the difference in the 80 the
growth rate of the 80 thousand from now
until 65 would be calculated at seven
percent ninety percent of the time
maybe maybe six but somewhere right in
there it's not going to be five hardly
ever and it's almost never going to be
eight okay so six or seven right in
there if you put that number into a
financial calculator on that stream of
payments that was would be what you
would generate
okay if that's the case then if you're
willing to roll this into a traditional
IRA
there's no taxes on it by doing that and
you were to invest it in a series of
good growth stock mutual funds averaging
north of 10 percent then you will end up
with more money and more income as a
result of more money is that you follow
me because - yeah 10 will be 7 at 12
will be 7 you know that kind of thing
and in addition to that when you die you
don't lose the money you're the money
goes to your heirs right if it's in an
IRA today if you die if you leave it in
the pension you lose the money if
there's a survivor benefit to your wife
your wife would get some but then when
she dies the money is gone but
ultimately the money's gone in a pension
when you know the people involved die
right right and so that has an actual
mathematical value that I'm not even
putting in the equation but if you're
willing to do that and not use the money
and not take a tax hit and cash it all
out and buy a truck with it as I'm
stupid if you're willing to roll it into
an IRA in mutual funds
90% of the time you're going to want to
do this when you crunch the numbers now
the way to determine that is sit down
with somebody that can run that
calculation for you go to Dave Ramsey
calm and click on endorse local provider
ELP for investing in your area one of
our guys that we endorse in the
investment world can run that number for
you in 10 or 15 minutes and show you
exactly what the comparison would be not
to mention the fact that when you die
the money survives you well it's amazing
that you said between 6 & 7 percent
while I was on hold I just modeled in
the spreadsheet and if I take that
82,000 and put it in an IRA I run out of
money in age 87 if I get 9% at age 87 I
have a 1 and a half million dollars and
I've also taken out the money yeah how
old are in it I have 45 ok see the
80,000 that did you did you run it out
as if you started draining it now or
started running it as ringing it at 65
yeah I did apples to apples versus what
I would get out of the pension
you got to grow it first and then drag
yeah right yeah so yeah you're here six
six point seven five was exactly on
target yeah it's really because pension
law dictates that from a fiduciary
standpoint that's how they handle that
stuff that's why I know that it's not
it's not they're not going to be much
off of that because they would be at
risk in terms of being sued by somebody
in the pension from their fiduciary
standpoint so you know they've got to do
that and that and that's why it shows up
so many times when I've run it over the
years so that's if that's what I'm sure
that's the discount rate they're using
then is that six seventy five or
somewhere in that range which tells you
if you're willing to invest it in
something that's going to do better than
that and the fact that your money
survives you it doesn't die with you
then it's a no-brainer to do a rollover
a direct transfer roll over into an IRA
and a good you know good mutual fund
broker with the heart of a teacher can
walk you through that if you don't have
one see one of our LPS hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you